[Applause]
[Music]
everybody is Charlie hopefully you've
had a chance to see black panther this
is gonna be my explanation of the
post-credits scenes there is a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video be sure to click that bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss any of
the videos either just because it is
kind of crazy with the Olympics right
now so careful for spoilers if you have
not seen Black Panther yet oh wait just
a second okay so first big one
Black Panther at the United Nations with
Everett Ross he's decided to fulfill a
promise that he made to Nakia to show
the world what what Condon's are capable
of she Nicoya have this thing where they
tail Black Panther through most of the
film they have his ear for very
different reasons so Nakia is a spy
working abroad for Wakanda just doing
general intelligence gathering so she
spends most of her time in the larger
world just seeing how things are in
knowing how much better it is in Wakanda
so because she's offering regular
reports on what's going on in the
broader world and she used to be his
girlfriend he just listens to what she
has to say but also a Koi a is the
leader of the Dorma logic so she's more
of a motherly big sister type but she's
very traditionalist she initially
believes that Wakanda should be more
isolationist but then they all sort of
come around like obviously Black Panther
isn't gonna make everybody happy as king
so fulfilling his promise to Nakia he
addresses the larger united nations and
says that they will no longer be
isolationist they'll open their borders
up they're not going to cloak it
visually with the shield like you see
them pass through it it's literally
cloaked from view and from sensors so
they're not gonna do that anymore if
they twist that ulysses klaw speech from
earlier and the bail money's talking to
Everett Ross and says what do you know
of Wakanda it Everett Ross says you know
textiles farming simple people delegates
of the United Nations sort of laugh at
black panther and say what does a bunch
of farmers have to offer the larger
world we're first world nations we quite
literally have all the money in the
power in the world in his badass way of
responding to that is sort of chuckling
and then it just dips to the credits as
if it's his I am Iron Man moment like
they're all sitting there at the
conference at the end of that first
Ironman film and he just flat-out gets
ready to tell them and you could just
picture him saying something like
vibranium yo but the reason why that's
such a big deal is is because it means
that he's going to be sharing what
Condon technology selectively at first
probably very slowly with the broader
world community meaning the you'll see
Wakanda and stuff pop up in the other
marvel cinematic films in the next ten
years there's actually been a new theory
that's popped up recently because black
panther is now sort of pushing Wakanda
and Technology and their ideas into the
broader world people are like wait a
minute what if black panther were to buy
the Avengers tower for Sheree and she
turned it into an outpost in New York
City for the wakandan technology group
that she runs so that's all speculation
at this point we don't really know how
they're gonna incorporate the wakandan
characters like Sheree and Black Panther
and anybody else from that film into the
future Marvel films but I think you can
assume there's gonna be a sequel and
they'll probably be a lot more crossover
so we'll probably learn more about that
after infinity war a lot of speculation
about the future of Black Panther
characters we'll have to wait till after
infinity war because we're literally
getting that in a couple months
speaking of infinity war ii post-credit
scene is what you would call the
infinity war teaser it basically serves
the purpose of explaining what happens
to Winter Soldier between the end of
civil war in the beginning of infinity
war because you see him at all these
trailer shots in Wakanda and yes he has
a new bionic arm that's made out of
vibranium yes they fixed his mind but
the other really deep cut from Marvel
Comics is that the children of the
village where he emerges from in the
scene are calling him the white wolf so
people like wait a minute does that mean
that they're gonna do white wolf in a
future Black Panther movie because that
character in the comics is actually
somebody who was sort of a stepbrother
to Black Panther he led the hood surahs'
a which is kind of like the spec ops
team within the idea of Dermalogica the
door Milosh a are this hardcore fighting
force they're totally badass during the
film I loved what they did with the
characters but the hadoo sera they are
meant to be in extra level intense above
that so the fact that they're canonizing
Winter Soldier as the white wolf means
that there's a good chance that he could
come back during that black panther
sequel but you have to remember that a
lot of actors are tender their contracts
so it just up for grabs just depends on
how they want to use the character going
forward but
now they have a really solid option if
you didn't see it I did a video a little
while ago explaining how Sheree D
programs his mind from all the Hydra
commands so that's the other big part of
this too is that is part of all the cool
technology and things that sure he's
able to do is that what Condon's also
have ai technology that's much more
advanced than the technology used to
create Ultron it obviously yes they did
have the mind gem at their disposal but
if Sheree is the key to understanding
things like that then obviously that's
gonna be a big plot point during
infinity war because they have to get
the mind gem out of vision so that
Thanos can put it in the gauntlet
without killing him in the process so it
kind of serves two purposes it fixes
Winter Soldier so there isn't like a big
plot hole when he just walks out looking
normal during infinity war it also
provides a logical way for how the
Avengers can understand the infinity
gems on level that they haven't before
because by the events of the first
Avengers film they had had the tesseract
for a long time still didn't know that
the Infinity gem was inside of it or how
it worked or how to use it without
blowing themselves up they just treated
it like it had a will of its own which
it kind of does the infinity gems do
have a low-level consciousness about
them the tesseract is misbehaving that's
supposed to be funny no it's not funny
at all the tesseract is not only active
she's behaving she's throwing off
interference radiation nothing harmful
low levels of gamma radiation that can
be harmful adjacent to that idea if you
guys didn't see it I did a spider-man
video about future armor that he might
have just explaining how Wakanda might
spread their technology to the greater
world in because spider-man and Sheree
will both be with the Avengers during
infinity work spider-man is a full-blown
Avenger we could consider Sheree an
honorary Avenger after the events of
infinity war I think it's safe to assume
that she's gonna survive both of those
movies so she can go on to phase four
and show up wherever they want a user
but this is her talking about helping
spider-man with his suit man Tom's my
friend and I was I was contemplating
helping him in the future with his suit
and stuff and just we were just going
back and forth but I think I would win
you know being what I did I know
realistically what I think that means is
is that everybody will get really cool
stuff and they might just say that
there's some wakandan technology built
into it like I gave you some help with
that but everybody isn't gonna roll out
looking the exact same with vibranium
gear
it's just that in some cases they'll be
more literal like Captain America shield
is literally a wakandan vibranium shield
in other cases it will be less visible
advancements like fixing winter soldiers
brain separating visions brain from the
mind gem but when we get into infinity
gem territory it's a little bit of
speculation I'm not expecting to see any
of that stuff in the trailers like we
haven't seen Thor with the Avengers in
any of the trailers even though he was
in that d23 footage
Thanos like grabbing his head like he
was gonna pop it like a grape there are
a couple things that they'll probably
just leave out of the trailers just
because they give away too many spoilers
but you can sort of put the dots
together so when we do get new footage
I'll talk about that there's supposed to
be a new infinity war promo Friday night
so I'll do a video for that whatever it
is that's probably not gonna post til
later in the evening though so just be
aware that that's gonna happen I will
post a more detailed spoilery review
tomorrow morning then obviously a whole
bunch of infinity war in the next couple
of weeks but leave all your video
requests if there's anything that you
want me to talk about specifically from
the movie or big questions you want me
to address just write it below in the
comments there is that new round of the
giveaway I'll name the winner when I
post that spoilery review in the morning
but click here to re-watch that infinity
war trailer and click here to learn all
about Thor's new weapon thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you